Solo: A Star Wars Story might not be the same
kind of box office bonanza that Disney has
gotten used to since adding Lucasfilm to its
menagerie of studios, but the film has still
given fans a lot to talk about.
Centered on the title space pirate as he makes
his way from the mean streets of Corellia
to his fabled Kessel Run, Solo gives the hesitant
hero some new cinematic life, with Alden Ehrenreich
stepping into Harrison Ford's old boots.
His journey fills in a lot of blanks about
Han Solo's past - up to and including the
origin of his name - and in the process churns
out quite a few references that were quite
clearly meant to ring familiar, even the most
casual fans in a galaxy far, far away.
Familiar parlance
It wouldn't be a Han Solo movie without some
of his choice catchphrases coming into play.
The easiest nods to the character's previous
pieces of dialogue were direct, like when
Han is referred to as a "flyboy" by his new
cohorts on Tobias Beckett's team, and when
he calls his budding sidekick Chewbacca a
"moof-milker" for what is probably the first
time of many.
At other points, the approach was to turn
an iconic phrase on its head.
Instead of the classic "I have a bad feeling
about this" line that makes its way into every
Star Wars movie, Han's delight at taking the
wheel inspires the happier version: "I have
a really good feeling about this."
And when Lando Calrissian has decidedly had
enough of the coaxium heist, and all the damage
it's doing to his precious Millennium Falcon,
and he tells Han, "I hate you," at which point
Han replies, "I know."
It's a nod to the signature exchange he'll
later have with Leia Organa and is clearly
meant to show the strong effect Han's had
on people since the beginning.
Too tough to tangle with
Solo also takes place before Rogue One: A
Star Wars Story, and the film overtly tells
us as much by including Scarif among the many
familiar planet names that are dropped by
characters throughout.
While there are plenty of other familiar locales
that should make Star Wars' aficionados' ears
perk, the mention of Scarif is about much
more than letting us know it's still intact
in the timeline of Solo.
It also reaffirms just how gutsy the events
of Rogue One really were.
The planet is mentioned by Qi'ra as a possible
source of some replacement coaxium, after
the team muffs their first attempt to boost
some from a train on Vandor-1.
Scarif is quickly passed over because of the
heavy security surrounding the planet, and
the group instead opts to risk the Kessel
Run with unstable explosives rather than even
take a chance at Scarif.
In other words, Jyn Erso and her little band
of rebels were even braver than we knew.
The seeds of rebellion
The first stand-alone Star Wars story, Rogue
One was basically a feature-length tribute
to some of the previously unknown heroes that
helped fuel the rebellion that would ultimately
topple an empire - by getting those Death
Star plans into Leia's hands.
Solo, on the other hand, is focused on the
history and character development of the galaxy's
most lovable rogue, and proves he was known
to act unselfishly on at least one occasion
prior to saving Luke Skywalker from Darth
Vader's squadron of TIE fighters.
What it means for Han to betray Dryden Vos
and deliver the precious fuel cells to Enfys
Nest's ragtag team is fairly epic.
Before, he was ready to align with anyone
who'd fill his pockets, but now he has scruples
and guts.
Enfys Nest tells Han that the coaxium is the
blood of a new rebellion.
In other words, long before Han would ever
meet Luke and Obi-Wan at that Cantina, he'd
already begun his work aiding the Rebel Alliance.
Let the Wookiee win
Some references are a little more obscure
than others, like when Lando Calrissian uses
his downtime to chronicle his adventures via
hologram and makes mention of the alien race,
the Sharu.
This is a major nod to the novel Lando Calrissian
and the Mindharp of Sharu, which hasn't
been considered "canon" but offers its own
sort of pre-war adventure tale of Lando and
a droid going on a treasure hunt.
The book and its sequels might not have gotten
much onscreen love in the past, but the scene
seems to finally give weight to those crazy
adventure stories.
Similarly, Solo also gives a nod to artists
Phil Tippett and Jon Berg's missing holochess
characters, Bulbous and Scrimp, which were
omitted from the Dejarik boards shown in A
New Hope and The Force Awakens but were kept
by the artists as souvenirs of their Star
Wars adventures.
In a Solo scene aboard the Millennium Falcon,
Chewbacca is shown learning the game with
Beckett and attempting to wipe the pieces
away in a moment of typical frustration, permanently
damaging the board in his fit of rage and
causing the two pieces to blink out of existence.
Who shoots first?
Perhaps no Star Wars issue has been so furiously
debated as whether or not Han Solo shot first
in his fateful showdown with Greedo.
Solo doesn't answer that specific question,
precisely, but it does pay respects to the
issue with a much more conclusive version
of some similar events.
In the film's final scenes, Han confronts
Beckett on the beach, after his pseudo-mentor
betrays him, and it becomes clear their differences
can't be resolved peacefully.
Using his signature blaster pistol, given
to him by Beckett, Han decides to act first
and whips out his weapon to put one into Beckett's
chest before Beckett can ever draw his own
sidearm.
Scum and villainy
Young Han is driven by two central desires:
rescuing his gal pal Qi'ra and earning his
wings as a bona fide pilot.
By the time we meet him in A New Hope, however,
he's become a wayward employee of Jabba the
Hutt, driven mostly by his greed, and the
bounty on his head.
Solo teases that future, even after painting
Han as the good guy for his contribution to
Enfys Nest's burgeoning rebellion, by telling
us what his next move will be.
Beckett mentions a rumor that "a big shot
gangster is putting together a crew" on Tatooine,
and Han decides to follow that lead.
That "big shot gangster" can only be Jabba
the Hutt.
That's where Han's headed, for better or worse.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!